[MUSIC]
As I was reflecting on the my assignment,
which is a balanced view of the Affordable
Care Act I thought back to Harry Truman,
who was President when I was a Stanford
undergraduate, and studying economics.
And President Truman was famously quoted
one day as saying, oh God,
give me a one-armed economist.
Otherwise you know, it's on the one hand
this and
on the other hand it's that [LAUGH].
And but Stanford was turning out two armed
economists in my day and
so you're gonna get a two-armed economist.
In thinking about the healthcare
situation, and
trying to place this is some historical
perspective, it's important
to bear in mind that the healthcare in
this country is changing rapidly.
It's a, it's you have to have a motion
picture.
If you just try to do a freeze frame
you'll miss an awful lot because a lot of
people will be thinking thoughts that were
relevant 10, 20, 50, 100 years ago.
And, so I thought I'd just start with a
little reminder of where we've come from.
If we go back to 19th century medicine,
say 1850 to 1950 physician culture was one
of autonomy, independence.
Nobody interfered with my decisions.
And even physicians who were students of
mine said,
I was taught don't depend on anybody else,
you're responsible.
Among other things in this culture, there
was a strong opposition
to group practice and doctors are
sometimes penalized.
In fact, the famous Russell Lee, who
founded the Palo Alto Clinic over here
was expelled from the Santa Clara County
Medical Society for
starting a multi-specialty group practice.
Later on I could explain to you the
economic reasoning that lead to that.
But that meant loss of hospital privileges
and, and a lot of other bad things.
the, the healthcare, the medical payment
of those days was fee-for-service,
with the doctor and the patient
negotiating the fee.
You know, I've often thought, you know,
when my kid is lying bleeding on
the operating table, this is not the time
when I wanna pull out my pocket financial
calculator and negotiate with the doctor
on, on what the fee is gonna be.
But fee-for-service has meant and still
means a strong incentive to, to resolve
all doubts and uncertainties in favor of
doing more and more costly services.
Well, also, back in that era, few people
had health insurance.
And that was okay because doctors really
couldn't do much anyway.
[LAUGH] also,
the doctor owns his own records and
doesn't share information with others.
And the, the view that, it's my patient
and
turf battles over you know, what part of
the body I own.
I remember I'm giving a talk like this
years ago to Stanford trustees and
one of them was my Stanford classmate Bill
McCall.
Who went on from his all-Americanism on
the football field to become an orthopedic
surgeon.
And he broke out laughing, he said, yes,
you know, the podiatrists and
the orthopedists are fighting over who
owns the ankle.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Also in this era, the focus was on
acute care.
That is, you have a problem, you come in.
The doctor listens to your story,
diagnoses, treats you, and that's it.
It's over, good bye.
And also, research showed very wide
variations in medical practice.
You know, people thought, oh, if you're a
doctor, then you know the right thing, and
there is one simple single right thing to
do and that's what you do.
But I remember my friend, Jack Linberg did
studies up in Vermont, where they broke up
the state into about ten different
hospital referral areas, and looked
to analyze to see what was the per capita
incidence of tonsillectomy in children.
And it varied tenfold.
Just huge variations and then he went on
to make a career documenting wide
variations in medical practice.
In other words, doctors don't all do the
same thing with the same kind of patient.
Partly as he ascribed it, because of
medical uncertainty.
Oh this was, this heading was meant to be
hospitals, but I'll talk about hospitals.
Generally there were free-standing
community hospitals, mostly nonprofit,
and the orientation of the hospital
administrator was to
fill the beds in order to cover the
overhead.
I remember years ago I was on the board of
a hospital in Santa Monica and
I was sitting there taking it all in and
the occupancy was down.
And people were talking to the hospital
administrator in
just the same terms that I remember as a
limited partner in a real estate venture.
We talked to our manager, what are you
gonna do to get the occupancy up?
And I was thinking, non evilly, gee, you
know, that's that's funny.
We ought to be happy that people are, are
healthier and
fewer of them need to be in the hospital.
And hospitals in those days began to
compete for
doctors with technology and, and
facilities.
I remember my friend, Dr. Paul Elwood
saying, what is it,
hospitals don't have patients, hospitals
have doctors, and doctors have patients.
Well, moving forward, then to the 20th
century.
Large scale health insurance came in at
about mid-century.
Really World War II was the, the big
watershed for that.
And one of the things that that meant was,
when people are insured,
they don't care what it costs, or whether
it's necessary or not.
They just want more of everything, cuz
somebody else is paying for it.
And so, previously, medical spending was
restrained by the patient's ability and
willingness to pay.
Now that that they got insurance, well
that's gone.
So in, especially in latter half of the
20th century,
there was a huge explosion of medical
knowledge in technology.
Exemplified, for example, by the fact that
in the year 2000 25,000 articles
were published reporting randomized
controlled trials that's around the world.
Just a huge number and so the second half
of the 20th
century there was this big struggle to
introduce spending restraint, you know?
Healthcare shot up from 5% of the GDP to
18% and how can we slow that down?
So the consequences of all of that for the
20th century were, first it cost too much.
Like, 18% of the GDP, straining public and
private finances.
A lot of bad quality care.
You know, people think oh, well, we got
the best healthcare system in the world.
That's not, obviously, if you look at it
up close.
I was reading an article the other day,
research indicating that something like
400,000 deaths happened in
hospitals per year because of errors and,
preventable errors.
We got to where there was poor access,
nearly 50
million people without health insurance
because it was kinda priced out of reach.
And employers, and Medicare, essentially
locked in their employees, or
their beneficiaries into what I call
open-ended-fee-for-service.
That is the traditional model of paying
for doctors.
And most people didn't even have a choice.
That is most employed people, they come to
work, and
the employer says, well this is our health
plan and that's it.
Instead of doing, let's say, what we do at
Stanford for our employees on healthcare,
is we say well, we're gonna offer you a
menu of five or
six different health plans that you might
pick.
And we will pay for the, the university
will pay for
the low price plan which around here is
usually Kaiser Permanente.
We think that's very good quality,
if you want something that costs more, you
pay the difference.
That's the basic idea of managed
competition.
so, more consequences in the 20th century,
a huge amount of waste.
A National Academy of Sciences report
estimated some 30 to
40% of healthcare spending in this country
is waste.
That is, it just does not benefit the
patient.
More and more consciousness of the fact
that we have an extremely complex
system, just wildly complex in, in, in
it's many aspects.
You just think there are thousands of
different insurance plan designs,
and different employers, so forth.
And so, think of the poor Palo Alto
Clinic, they've,
these people with huge number of different
health plan designs.
So they've gotta figure out now for each
person, what is it that the insurance
pays so we can bill the insurance, and
what is it the patient pays?
And so you have very large clerical staffs
in these organizations.
And physicians overwhelmed by new medical
information.
Just not possible for the ordinary single
doc now, to keep up with it all.
That's one of our problems.
Then, let me just move forward to 21st
century medicine.
I think the future is becoming integrated
delivery systems.
That is, with an ethos of, and a culture
of teamwork,
shared responsibility for patients.
Instead of the doc thinking it's my
patient.
Now a team of doctors from different
specialties,
if it's a complicated patient, need to
work together.
It's our patient and we need to share
information.
And use our resources as best we can.
With integrated delivery systems the
important thing is the incentives
of all the players are aligned with what
Dr, Berwick called the triple aim,
that is better health, better care, and
lower cost.
That's, that's where
we need to move the system.
What else with 21st century medicine.
Teams develop up-to-date practice
guidelines.
You know, with the 25,000 new randomized
trials published each year,
you really need a system, a teamwork
system to create useable knowledge.
And to turn the new discoveries into
recommendations for
the physicians for how to take care of
that kind of patient.
We're moving into standardization, and
simplification.
A focus on chronic conditions.
I mentioned earlier, with 19th century
medicine, it was, it was acute care.
Now, about three quarters of the costs
of healthcare are for people with chronic
conditions.
With diabetes, congestive heart failure,
et cetera, et cetera, depression.
And a very promising development, in my
view,
that's starting to come into play now,
is some of the large benefits consulting
firms have created a benefits exchanges.
Aon, Towers, Mercer have done this.
So they contract, let's see Aon contracted
with Walgreen's that they will put before
each patient, each worker, a menu of maybe
five or six different choices.
And the employer will make a fixed defined
contribution,
and like Stanford then the employee will
make his choice.
And I think that's just crucial, to me
that's the highest priority thing is just
breaking out of the, of the situation
where people don't have choices and
into a kind of market, market model.
And that's, that's starting to happen now.
Okay, that brings us to the Accountable
Care Act, Affordable Care Act,
which happened in about 2010.
A good thing there are exchanges which
we've all
heard about because the implementation was
so grievously blotched.
But for people who don't have employers to
broker,
to arrange their health insurance they can
go to the exchange.
Now, I think exchanges, as I was saying
earlier,
are a very good and important and
necessary idea.
My regret that I expressed to the
Obama-nauts was,
that ought to cover everybody, not just
people who don't have an employer.
At least we ought to have every firm up
to, say, 200 employees.
I sometimes wonder, why not?
[LAUGH] I mean that's the American way, to
give people responsible choices.
Anyway, so that's,
that's a prominent well known feature of
the of the Affordable Care Act.
Also, other features, they enacted what's
called the Cadillac tax,
an excised tax of 40% on the excess
of family premiums, over $27,500 a year.
That sounds wild but I mean, normal
projections isn't where things are going,
is we'll be there by 2018, when this thing
kicks in.
And a lot of employers are starting to
work hard, including Stanford.
How can we avoid that tax, how can we keep
the premiums down?
They also, to pay for the expanding
coverage, they reduced Medicare
hospital patients, essentially, payments,
essentially with Medicare.
The government was saying each year we'll
increase your payments by the amount of
inflation and the cost of doing hospital
business plus 1%.
Well they took the 1% away.
Probably fine.
They created what are call, called
accountable care organizations Auh,
to modify the incentives for doctors and
hospitals caring for Medicare patients.
The idea with the Accountable Care
Organization is, again, to
bring some teamwork and com, cooperation
into the, into the situation by
doctors and hospitals accepting
responsibility for
moderating the growth in per-person
expenses.
And if they can hold the cost to less than
the projections,
then they get half the savings.
Now I've been rather skeptical of that
because I think the incentives are far too
weak.
It'd be better if we just had a market,
and they said, here you are, guys.
If you don't really, you know, give
patients a good deal,
high quality, good service, and so forth,
you're just gonna lose your business.
Instead, it was,
if you don't slow the growth in spending,
you won't get this bonus.
Sometimes the way I put it is, is, there
we are in the board room with the doctors
and hospitals and someone in the back of
the room who is skeptical says,
You mean to tell me if we cut our revenue
by a million dollars,
then, we'll get to keep, we'll give,
they'll give us back 500,000.
Well, why don't we just keep the whole
million?
[LAUGH] There's a problem with the
incentives.
I think, I think one of the problems is
that people who
designed this law didn't study economics
very much, at least,
they don't
>> [LAUGH].
>> And finally, there was the Independent
Payment Advisory Board
which was to 15 wise persons we sit back
and if Medicare spending
grows too much, then they could
essentially make recommendations that
would have the force of law, without
checks and balances and so forth.
That hasn't happened so far and it
probably won't.
My guess is nobody's gonna want that job.
Now what have they done?
I've talked about the big problems of
access, cost, quality.
What what does it do for these problems?
Well one good thing is they encourage and
subsidize the adoption of information
technology.
Another is to penalize hospitals for me,
medicare cases for
readmissions within 30 days.
A generally accepted marker of a, of a
poor treatment.
Generally speaking, I would say,
with our very large quality problems, the
Affordable Care Act didn't do much.
For access to care the act provided
Medicaid for
individual adults with incomes up to 1.3
times the federal poverty line.
And for people with incomes higher than
that through the exchanges,
there would be subsidies for
people with incomes all the way up to four
times the federal poverty line.
That's, for a family of four, that's like
$94,000, $9,400.
Guaranteed issue, guaranteed renewal.
That is today, if an insurance company is
selling an insurance plan to the public,
they have to take all comers, the sick and
the healthy.
So guaranteed renewal, you can't take away
the pol, policy when the person gets sick.
And an individual mandate, that is a law
that if you don't have health insurance,
you have to pay what economists call a
free writer tax.
That is, if you don't have health
insurance, you know that when
you get smashed up on the freeway, and you
get taken in the emergency room.
By law, for many years, the hospital has
to take care of you,
at least stabilize you.
And so there's been growing concern about
free writing.
I mean a lot of people are, there's a kind
of health insurance there.
But the Affordable Care Act is definitely
reducing the number
of people who are uninsured, from
something like 50 million to 30 million.
With complexity, I think it just made the
whole problem worse.
I mean, the thing is bewilderingly
complex.
What about fragmentation?
Well, I talked about an accountable PR
organization.
The team of physicians and hospitals that
contract their Medicare,
the slow cost growth while maintaining
quality.
And then they can keep half the savings.
I think Accountable Care Organizations are
an important step in the right direction.
I just regret that that they didn't make
the incentives stronger,
because they need to be.
It's a step toward an integrated health
care delivery system.
You hear a lot of complaints about counter
productive taxes.
To pay for all this they imposed a 2.3%
excise tax on drugs and
devices and the device manufacturing
companies complained that we
are starting to pay taxes on the revenues
even before we make any profits on the,
on the product.
And so it's been, I think, justly
criticized as being anti innovation.
Similarly, there's a tax on, on insurers
that this is kind of an obscure point,
but nobody likes insurance companies, so
we're gonna make them pay.
Well, the problem is the tax falls heavier
on insurance companies at their risk.
Then half of employed people are then
employers who are, or
the employers self-insured.
There's no insurance company maybe to
process the claims.
Anyway, it's a tax that works against risk
bearing, which I think is a mistake,
because, what we need is to get insurance
companies bearing the risk and
then to making deals with doctors and
hospitals to share the risk,
to transfer the risk for the cost of care
to doctors and hospitals.
And I think the employer mandate is
anti-jobs.
It's my first reaction when I saw the
whole thing was,
if I was the CEO of a company, I would say
don't hire anybody.
Wait till, because it takes away the
ability, of course,
all employers, like, 98% of employers of
more than, then 200 people do
provide health insurance but it takes away
their flexibility,
their ability to modify it to save money,
because it's all under federal regulation.
So, summary comments.
Getting everyone covered is an important
goal.
I believe in that.
I really think it's wrong to, to have a
situation in which many
people don't have access to healthcare
because, especially children,
because they, they can't afford it.
And we really ought to have universal
health insurance.
And the Affordable Care Act is a serious
attempt to get there.
I hear some people criticize it and say we
want to repeal it and replace it,
and now that I am listening, do I hear
what the replacement is going to be?
And that's why, you know I have some
friends who want to, you know,
I'd like to hear little more about I mean,
the Republicans,
I think, could, could improve their whole
story if they would get together and
come out with a credible and coherent
alternative.
I think that the whole thing is far too
complex, and it keeps changing.
Nancy Pelosi famously said along the way,
we're going to have to pass this law in
order to find out what's in it.
[LAUGH] And, and I'm pretty good friends
with our benefits manager, who,
because I am, I chair the advisory
committee and from time to time we
say well, four years have gone by and we
still don't know what's in it.
You know, the president is changing it all
the time.
Slipping this deadline and that.
And I think that there's some serious over
reach.
I think we could of had universal health
insurance in this country without passing
a law that forces Georgetown University
and Notre Dame University for,
as employers for example to provide what
they consider to be abortifacients.
That is, abortion causing drugs.
We just didn't have to take that issue on
in, in this prob, problem.
Professor Uwe Reinhardt of Princeton
described it as an ugly patch
on an ugly system, that's, referred as a
complexity and so forth.
And I think it's too bad that they didn't
break the link to employer-sponsored
insurance, and go for a simplified, really
universal health insurance.
Which, for example, in the late, you know,
latter part of the,
last decade, Senator Wyden from Oregon and
Senator Bennett from Utah purposed, as did
the comity for economic development, there
are ways you could do it.
I mean there's just a lot wrong with it
adds to the cost and
complexity, etc, of employer based health
insurance.
We're all used to it.
But it is that the, at the heart of, of,
why we have these problems.
So, there we are.
Thank you for your time and interest and
good, good luck with your affordable
health insurance.
[LAUGH] Questions?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
They, they wanna give you a mic.
Yeah.
Right.
>> Yes Medicare when it first was passed
wasn't perfect either.
And there have been a lot of changes that
made it much better over the years.
And how can we change the Affordable Care
Act to make it better too?
what, what would you suggest.
>> Well.
>> For single payer or like,
Medicare, or do we do something else?
>> Well I think first of all, with the
subsidies, they are means tested.
You know?
So that the,
the exchange has to go to the IRS to get
last years tax reported.
It's a, and.
>> [COUGH].
>> Taxable income reported and so forth.
So, I would say the subsidy payments or
the premium support payments
ought to apply on a flat basis across the
income spectrum and
not be means tested at that level except
for, if you, if you want means testing,
which I think is okay, then you would say
these premium support payments
would be reported to the IRS and included
in the recipient's taxable income.
So that would reduce some of the cost,
cost to the government.
But that would be one, one major thing.
Let me just say, if you say what do I
think we ought to have,
[LAUGH] depressingly it has been 30 or so
years since I proposed,
published in the New England Journal of
Medicine, consumer choice health plan.
And the idea was, in effect, universal
health insurance based
on regulated competition in the private
sector.
So everybody, the whole country, oughtta
look like what we do at Stanford.
Which is, we offer, our employees a range
of choices where
they are responsible for the costs above
the cost of the low cost plan.
And what happens, is, people will migrate
to what they see as value for money.
>> Okay.
In the, in the interest of transparency,
I have to reveal that I'm a retired
physician.
And I'm currently, now, I am a hospital
medical administrator.
So I've, we've dealt with some of these
things.
One of the problems, even, with the, with
the exchanges, and
some of the plans, is that people tend to,
sometimes, pick the cheapest plan.
The bronze plan was basically have a 40%
deductible and
I had to deal with a woman the other day,
came to our emergency room who had
a $5,000 bill and here she had $2,000 that
she was responsible for.
Now she didn't have very much money, she
complained, oh I thought I had insurance.
You know, that, that seems to be, it's a
kind of a trap for many people.
They think they're insured.
>> Right.
>> But they actually aren't completely
insured.
>> Yeah.
That's a very good point.
I wish I had included that in my prepared
remarks.
Some of this is pretty lousy insurance,
you know, with very high deductibles.
And, for a lot of people, they're just not
gonna be able to afford,
the, of the deductible.
So, I think what happens there, is,
there are some people in the political
world, for whom it's more important for
us to be able to say they're insured, then
for them actually to be insured.
In my consumer choice health plan
proposal,
there'd be a standard coverage contract
and there'd be much less deductibles.
The cost consciousness would come in the
premium.
Yes?
>> question.
>> Was there any estimate made?
>> Pardon me?
>> How much it's costing the dot comer,
to 20 million people?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[SOUND].
>> How much-
>> Has there been any estimate made of how
much it's costing the nation not to
cover the 20 million people.
>> I expect there probably have been.
One doesn't come to mind immediately, but
that's a good question.
Because those people well, I'll tell you
just an example,
I was talking with Senator Bob Bennett who
was
senator from, Utah and I thought a very
good guy, but
fairly conservative, but more conservative
people in Utah fired him.
And I remember he was talking to me about
this plan that he and
Senator Wyden were proposing.
He said, you know, I say to people, we
already have universal health insurance.
I mean, you can go to the hospital if
you're sick, and be cared for free.
But the problem with that is.
That's a very expensive way of doing it.
Because those people should have had
access to primary care doctor who
would catch their problem early and treat
them and
keep, keep them from needing the hospital.
And so I think there is a real cost, to
having people without health insurance.
But it comes in, in disability and work
days lost school days lost you know, etc.
And it'd be a good project to try to add
that all up.
Yes.
>> So do you think or, how far are we from
a,
a truly universal health insurance similar
to what's in U.K. or Canada?
>> Well, we are at least 30 million people
away from that.
I mean that, you know, it's, it's somewhat
uncertain, there are varying estimates.
I just picked that as what the
congressional budget office
said some time ago.
The number will vary, there are many
states with
Republican governors who decided that
they're not going to
expand Medicaid up to everybody at 1.3
times the federal poverty line.
And so, the score would be better if they,
as some states are doing now,
negotiate with the government saying well,
we are willing to expand coverage,
but we wanna do it in a more market
oriented way or whatever.
So it's a, it's an uncertain and variable
number.
But take 30 million as an approximation.
Yes.
Back here.
>> How does your, I think you called it
the Community Health Plan and
or the Widen Bennett Plan, break the
linkage to employment or
not and how do these plans address free
riding?
>> Well, let's see, they, in that model,
your insurance would not be linked to
employment.
In fact I even what's wrong with employer
sponsored health insurance?
It locks most people into open-ended fee
for service because employers don't have
a very good re, record of, of offering
choices.
Means you lose your job, if you lose your
job you lose your insurance.
Employers use it to compete for
employees by making their, the insurance
ever more generous.
You know, we pay for everything.
Come to work for us and we pay for
everything, etc.
including, nobody understands their health
insurances.
Probably if I asked for a show of hands
here and
said, how many of you, have actually read
your health insurance contract.
[LAUGH] Actually read it.
[LAUGH] Take a show of hands.
And iff somebody raise their hand I say,
did you understand it?
[LAUGH] So, a consumer choice health plan
I
had in mind is relatively simple standard
definition of the insurance contract,
it wouldn't include a very high
deductible.
eh, but you wouldn't look to the, your
employer anymore.
You would look to the, the exchange where
you, you'd get a subsidy.
Now, what I proposed was that,
like Stanford your, the low-price plan
would be paid for.
And if you wanted something more
expensive,
then you'd have to pay the difference, and
that would bring market forces to bear.
And Wyden-Bennett a, a similar idea.
now, what about free riders?
Well, the Affordable Care Act does have
what economists refer to as a tax on free
riders.
So if you don't, you could have health
insurance free, mister.
And if you don't, then you know, you'll,
you'll have to pay this tax.
Now I, I do think that the free rider tax
on the Affordable Care Act is,
is gonna be problematic and difficult to
collect and enforce and so forth.
But, that, that, that's the best answer
out there.
>> Dr.Antoven I, I have the microphone,
[INAUDIBLE].
>> Oh, okay.
>> Thank you.
Great talk.
I'm I'm married to an MBA.
I'm a physician, and I have a question
that's been talked about in
the doctors lounges and in the boardrooms
of hospitals.
You so casually referred to the 30-day
readmission rate as
a marker of care somehow.
And a, are you aware, or do you have a
comment on,
that we have no control over the
noncompliant patient, the mentally ill
patients, and those with chronic diseases,
who leave against medical advice.
Or they bounce out,
don't take their medicines, and they come
back within 30 days.
And we care so much about those patients,
but
we have no control over their behavior
once they leave.
>> Well, it is a challenge, and
I just think [LAUGH], and I think you have
to work on it.
The problem.
The problem comes from, I think, a large
part,
that when the patient leaves the hospital
they ought to be part of the delivery
system that right away picks them up and
puts them into the ambulatory care system.
And works with them to make sure that they
have their medications,
and that they take their meds and, and you
know, do whatever they
can instead of, you know, in the hospital,
I've experienced like,
like wife has baby and in a wheel chair,
we take her to the hospital door.
And the car pulls up, and they put him in,
and then, [SOUND] you know, goodbye.
[LAUGH] With, without a lot of careful
preparation for
what's supposed to happen after they leave
the hospital.
It's there are gonna be some 30 day,
within 30 day readmissions for
the many reasons that you [COUGH]
enumerated.
But it's important to work on those post
hospitalization problems.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yes?
>> How many, how many years before it
becomes evident to
Congress that there's a, a big flaw in the
act,
whether it's cost containment or some
other portion of the act and
Congress has to do something new, and then
what will they do?
>> [LAUGH] well, one thing is, one thing
is
Obama and the Democrats have no shortage
of
critics who are pointing out the various
flaws.
And so it's hard to pick up a newspaper
without reading about one or
another of the flaws in the Affordable
Care Act and I, I've mentioned a few,.
When, when, whether and when the Congress
will act to fix them, it, beats me.
But, I would say the direction they ought
to go is to make it more universal,
more cost contained.
One of my big complaints about about the
Affordable Care Act is
I think nobody should just be offered
open-ended fee for service fully paid.
I think, like Stanford employees, you,
you outta have a subsidy that pays a fixed
dollar amount, pays your
way into a good quality integrated
delivery system or whatever is out there.
And then, you have an incentive to choose
the economical system.
And will we ever get there?
I don't know.
You know, we might,
probably not in my lifetime.
Dr. Beethoven?
>> Yeah.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> I,
>> Oh, okay.
>> Thank you for
your decades of wonderful work in this
area,
I'm delighted to hear you today.
I'm an OB GYN physician.
I just wanna try to encourage you
to open your mind a little more about the
reproductive health issues.
I see women in those decisions.
And, you know, in America we are free from
religious persecution,
that's how America was founded.
And I think that if we agree that women
deserve reproductive health,
we've agreed that women deserve that, and
that needs to be apart of our health
insurance regardless of
religious organizations having their own
personal points of view.
So I encourage you to change your thinking
on that.
>> Well, one good thing about, [APPLAUSE]
one good thing about about breaking
the link between employment and health
insurance, I, I probably should have.
Next time I do this, I'm gonna put that on
the slide.
Is then, the employer is not involved in
the issue of the contents of your health
insurance, and I just don't think it's,
that it's a necessary or
appropriate thing to have the employer
involved in that.
It ought to be just you know, out there on
its own merits.
So yeah, that, that,
that would be one, it's, it's just, seemed
to me it was unnecessarily seeking or
bringing about conflict that didn't need
to occur.
Yes?
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> [INAUDIBLE] Gotta get the mic.
Here it comes.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> My bad.
I'm puzzled by the the difference in
billing between what
the insurance company pays, and what,
there's a number that's like four,
five times as high that appears on the
bill which as,
as far as I can tell, applies to anybody
who can't afford to pay at all.
[LAUGH] And they're the only ones that
have to pay that number.
That, that doesn't make any sense to me.
And it's true of hospitals.
>> Yeah.
>> Is that true of me doctors, et cetera?
>> Right.
It doesn't make any sense.
It's crazy.
Let me explain where I, you know, how
could this thing happen?
It turns out that hospitals have a very
substantial number of patients who got
there through the emergency room.
And, if this is a hospital that is not in
the network of the insurance
company covering the patient, then the
poor guy is, is at their mercy.
You know, they can just and that they,
they make a lot of money that way.
Cuz, people say, well why do they do that?
And nobody pays that.
Well.
Some people do pay it, and
support people who are there as a result
of an emergency, or urgent situation.
And, and I think that that's wrong.
I think I would favor some kind of a law
that would say,
you can't charge more than, you know,
something like 1.5 times Medicare or, your
know, some reasonable limit.
Otherwise it's just it's just extorting
people from, you know, it's taking
advantage of the fact that, that people
are, are sick and it.
Especially for a non-profit institution I
think it's particularly in,
you know, inappropriate and wrong.
Maybe this, maybe the thing to do, you
know, people have made the point that
hospitals engage in a lot of business that
for profit companies do also.
So, the for
profit companies refer to the non profit
hospitals as not tax paying hospitals.
We're investor owned tax paying hospitals.
Well, so that, that's been an issue.
Perhaps the way to get at it would be to
say, to change the law to say if you
are a non profit hospital then you will
not charge emergency
patients more than 1.5 times Medicare, or
something like that.
Oh, wanna give him the mic?
Oh.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Oh, somebody back there.
>> Professor Antoven.
Some have suggested that, due to the
intransigence of Congress,
the divisiveness, that the inevitable
outcome for
the country is a Canada style socialized
medicine for
the masses, has a separate tier of premium
care for those who can afford it.
Do you think this is where we're heading?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> [BLANK_AUDIO]
You know, I, I, I don't know.
I think the Canadian system works pretty
well for Canadians, but I,
I don't think it would work here.
I, I don't see that out there.
It's, it's a good question.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Will congress act on something?
[LAUGH] Oh, only reluctantly and in a
complex and confused way.
[LAUGH]
Dr.Burnett?
>> The recent,
>> This is Dr.Burnett, my friend.
[LAUGH].
>> Recent study by University of
California showed that hospital led,
healthcare delivery systems controlled by
physicians were at least 20% cheaper
than hospitals that didn't, medical
delivery systems controlled by hospitals.
And the, there are many ways and positions
even in the beeper
service system, can be peer reviewed and
under control.
And have some future limitations on costs
there,
I don't see any in hospitals, and I.
Think about the affordable care act.
And having the group of hospitals and
physicians.
It's still going to be dominated by the
ones that have the capital
which are the hospitals.
There fearing,
there's not lots of hospitals per
population in many areas of country.
And how do you, what do you think is a
solution, to make this more efficient
a system from the hospital side, not just
from the medical side?
>> That's a very good question.
I'd like to say, Doctor Burnett has been a
pioneer in this area.
In phys, he's a physician leader, in
physicians getting organized to
bring down the cost, and improve the
quality, and so forth.
Bob, I just read that article yesterday.
The author, Jamie Robinson, is a good
friend of mine, and I could, and through
the Integrated Healthcare Association I've
kind of seen that research progress.
And what had happens is the hospital
owned.
Medical groups cost 1.41 times the
non-hospital.
It's a very remark, marked difference,
now, my reaction to that was,
well you know, the problem is with
hospital administrators,
their whole orientation has been heads and
beds.
Keep the, keep the hospital full to, to be
able to.
Pay the overhead costs which is usually
large.
And keep the CT Scanners, scanning.
And keep all that stuff to bring in
revenue and
the whole orientation of the efficient
delivery system, is lets do everything
we can to keep the people healthy and keep
them from leaving the hospital.
And see if we can empty those hospitals
beds.
It's kind of a completely different
orientation and mindset.
And so, I don't think that hospital
administrators have the right
to mindset an ethos to be leaders in in
the healthcare systems.
And it, it ought to be physicians.
Like, like you and
your colleagues who pioneered in creating
physician organizations.
Over here.
>> Yes.
My question's sort of a follow up.
But with a little different spin.
The United States has far and
away the most expensive care per capita of
any developed country.
And we have the worse outcomes on average.
>> Right.
>> And all those other countries,
where they spend less money and
they get better outcomes basically are
single payer systems.
And for the life of me, I cannot
understand why there isn't more serious,
you know, consideration of a single-payer
system in a capitalist country where we
should be concerned about keeping the cost
and getting better outcomes.
>> Well, I guess it's partly a problem
that I, I have an attitude which was.
Developed, I, I spent four years as an
assistant secretary of defense and
my job was to, to bring cost effectiveness
into defense decision making.
And it's quixotic task for a young man.
>> [LAUGH].
>> What I learned was things like the
ideal weapon system is built in
435 district, Congressional districts.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You know.
And, and if I look at Medicare, the pork
barrel,
the log-rolling etcetera, I just don't see
any.
I don't wanna sound like a right wing
fanatic, but
this is, I was listening to democratic
administration that I learned this.
It's just there are not enough people
seriously interested in the total, and
holding down the total cost.
And, and well let me come at it another
way.
I think it was justice Brandeis who said,
that our system of government was based,
was built, to prevent the arbitrary
exercise of power.
You know, so you think of Madison, and
ambition must be made to check ambition.
So that, so nothing could get done In
contrast to the parliamentary system,
which is a system that's very good for
managing public programs.
So Brandeis we'are saying, our system of
governing is not built for the management,
effective management of public programs.
A huge difference between the
Parliamentary system and
the system of checks and balances that we
have.
Just to go on for
a moment, I've done some work on the
British National Health Service
at the invitation of the British people to
come over.
And, and they've got their problems,
I grant you for half the share of GDP,
they get better outcomes.
I think for some, some interesting
reasons.
And anyway, so I was asked to, how, how
could we bring some market forces and
competition into the business national
health service?
So there's a stature.
Picked up on my ideas and tried to
implement them.
And so the doctors didn't like it.
And I was invited to lecture to the London
medical society.
And this doctor got up and said we live.
We have an elective dictatorship.
She can do whatever she wants and there's
nothing we can do about it.
[LAUGH] And so I said in reply, well,
that's all very well, but I come from a
country that doesn't have any government.
[LAUGH] It's all, all checks and
balances and so I, I just don't think
it's, our form of government is built for.
The affect of management of public
programs,
we can see that all over the place.
>> I mean, my husband and I just went on
Medicare not that long ago.
>> Yeah.
>> That is a kind of a single care system.
>> I wonder how
many people in this auditorium on Medicare
would wanna get rid of it?
>> Well I think it outta be-
>> You know, it's a single-
>> Okay.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> I, I, I think Medicare ought to be
phased into a new model,
which it, resembles what we do at Stanford
for our employees.
That is, the government, by the way,
several bipartisan commissions and
groups have recommended that we do this.
One of the problems with Medicare that
we've had is that we can't afford it.
Other than that, it's very nice.
[LAUGH] And so the alt, the alternative
would be
what are called premium support payments
and competing systems.
And, and I think that's, that would be the
way, the way to go.
It, it comes back to Doctor Verniscuay.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Oh, Doctor Burnett's question about
what are we gonna do about the expensive
hospital controlled delivery systems.
And my favorite answer would be subject
them to real competition,
informed consumers, cost conscious
consumers.
And they'd have to.
Bring in leaders who want to give value
for money.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
I just, I, I worked in the Senate in the
early' 90s, with a bipartis,
for Senator Lieberman, in a bipartisan
group of senators who were moderates.
Trying to implement, essentially, your
policy in the.
>> Yeah.
>> This mainstream coalition
Managed Competition act.
And a key, the key thing that I wanted you
to,
just bring out a little bit more in this
discussion,
cause I think it's really critical for
people especially as we go into voting.
And I will disclose that I, my group at
Yale built the 30 day readmission
measures, and my husband works for Obama.
So I have my, my points of view but I hear
you saying, break the link
to employer to employer mandated plans,
and also that what you're.
Proposing is subsidized or supported
minimum plans
with the competitive environment, a
managed competitive environment now.
I just, I wanna make sure that people
understand that what I,
and I would like you to just contrast, if
you can, that what.
Advocates in congress right now who are
advocating changing, or repealing, or,
or wholesale change of the Affordable Care
Act.
That's not what they're talking about
'cause you're talking about
universal coverage, guaranteed benefit,
and managed competition.
Whereas people who are, you know, running
campaign ads right now
to pull down the Affordable Care Act are,
as you say they don't really say much.
But that's not the direction you're going.
You're going in a very constructive,
actually essentially universal coverage
direction.
The are advocating for just wholesale
repeal or we're not sure what.
And I, I'm wondering if you can draw that
conscious because there really is no
mainstream Senators anymore, right?
It's a very polarized environment.
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
I want everybody to understand I'm not a
adherent of either political party I'm in
the party of the plague on both your
houses.
[LAUGH].
So I'm trying to avoid being partisan, and
I just put, I put the point earlier, very,
very gently which was, I have yet to hear
from the Republicans, when they say
repeal and replace, I have yet to hear,
and I'm listening for the replacement.
and, and, oh, three senators from some
place got together and,
and put out a plan but it didn't deal with
the big problems.
So, I, I accept that point that it's the,
I,
I think the critics ought to be able to
explain.
This is what I would do.
Which I've done, in writing.
[INAUDIBLE].
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> So my question is about the accountable
care organizations.
And to me that's about the only way right
now that's linking, right now on a fee for
service there's no link between the
service provided and the outcome.
>> Yeah.
>> And the ACO is
the only model that will link service and
outcome.
>> Right.
>> And so it seems like they planned to
roll that out or to apply it across the
health system is really very limited.
Can you talk a little bit about what the
plan is for bringing A.C.O.s out?
And, and it, it's seems like there's just
this very small fraction rather than
this much bigger part that they should be?
>> Okay.
Let me put it this way.
We've got an awful lot of people in the
healthcare system that are still back in
the 19th century.
[LAUGH] And I, I told you about the 19th
century.
And maybe it's because they were taught
through the residency people,
person during the residency program, don't
rely on anybody else,
you know, you're an individual, your
responsible.
So we've got a lot, lot of mindsets from
those olden days that have to be changed.
And I think the idea with the Affordable
Care Act, I mean
with the Accountable Care Organizations,
the idea was to start that process.
To get doctors and
hospitals to collaborate with some
responsibility for quality and cost.
So the ACO's do have a lot of quality
measurement involved.
And so that was a, a step, as I said in my
talk, a step in the right direction.
I just think that the incentives ought to
put it on steroids.
Yes sir?
>> Doctor, is this on?
Doctor Antoven.
I have a business, so I'm an employer.
And not large enough to offer multiple
programs to my employees.
And I have to make the choice every year
of what their healthcare's gonna be.
I hate it.
It's a, it's a horrible responsibility,
and I can't wait till we get to these
exchanges.
Where I can just pay the bills, and just
let somebody else.
>> All right.
>> Choose.
But I have noticed.
This is the first year in which our costs
did not go up so
much that we had to change our program.
We actually, 8.25% increase in costs is
the lowest it's been in the last 14 years.
And we are able to keep the very same
program fr a second year.
Though, do you have any sense of what the
cost trajectory is,
since we're now in what, the third or
fourth year of the ACA.
>> Okay, that's a very good question.
You're going to get a two armed answer.
[LAUGH] Starting back.
In around 2002, it had been, we'd gone for
50 years or
whatever, with the growth in the national
health spending each year
being about 2.5 percentage points higher
than the growth of the GDP.
And starting back about then.
The gross rate relative to the GDP
moderated considerably came down to about
1% and economists have analyzed it in
detail and so forth.
There isn't a consensus about what brought
it about.
I mean people talk about a lot of things
like.
Expensive drugs coming off patent or maybe
just push back another eh,
another thing maybe doing it is a lot of
employers have gone
to high deductibles for their health plans
very big increase in high deductibles
etcetera, and so the, the growth has
moderated.
I don't ascribe that to the Affordable
Care Act.
I don't think anybody else does either.
It started before the Affordable Care Act.
Let's hope it continues.
But I, I think that I think that high
deductibles.
May help for a while, but I, I think, in
the longer run, that, that's not gonna be
the answer because once people you know,
like, say you have a $1,500 deductible.
You can't even walk past Stanford hospital
without being out $1,500.
[LAUGH].
[COUGH] So
there you are in the hospital and they so,
oh, you, you've.
You've used up your 1500 and you wring
your hands and say, oh damn,
there goes my 1500, now bring on the
technology.
And then, then you're back to the cost
unconscious situation.
And so I doubt that high deductibles.
And there are other problems and so on and
so forth, but we don't have a good answer.
Yes?
>> In the first two years of
the Clinton administration, they tried to
do something constructive and
were punished viciously at the polls.
My senator, Robert Bennett who you spoke
of, tried to do something constructive
about healthcare and was punished
viciously, viciously at the polls.
And it appears that the Democrats, having
been punished for
Obamacare fairly badly in the recent past,
are about to be punished again.
Does this suggest that there's any
chance that any sensible politician will
try to do any of things you believe in?
>> [LAUGH].
[SOUND].
>> Well I don't know.
I, I think.
>> [LAUGH].
>> It is remarkable, the negative reaction
to HillaryCare.
Because it wasn't even implemented.
I think the non-passing of, of, of, of
Hillary's 1342 page bill.
I'd been back there advising on it, so I
was following it with some interest.
Is that she and our magaziner and the
legislative draftsmen kind of went in
to the back room and wrote up the whole
thing.
They had a big task force of 500 people.
I was back there for a while wondering
around the halls of
the executive office building, until I
gave up.
And so they presented it to the Congress,
and I can just picture the scene,
some representative looks out the window
and sees the bill sitting there on the.
On the front steps that says, that's not
my baby.
And over there some Senator looks and says
I'm not the father.
And that's very different from the way
Lyndon Johnson did Medicare.
Lyndon Johnson I'm told wrote one page
description,
this is what Medicare ought to be.
Wilbur Cohen, my Secretary of Health and
Human Services, you've taken over to
Wilbur Mills, the Chairman of the Ways and
Means, and you start working it out.
And if you agree, if we can get, and, so,
you know,
all the people in the Congress got to put
their fingerprints on it.
And it sort of grew organically.
If you agree, then we'll lock arms and
walk forward and say we have Medicare.
So you have to involve the Congress.
And it is, it is dangerous territory.
At the time with, when, with Hillary Care
failed, we all said,
oh it'll be another 20 years before they
try again.
And maybe it'll be [LAUGH] another 20
years.
Although I have some hope that the private
sector through exchanges might be [SOUND].
Able to reform the system a lot.
[MUSIC]
[BLANK_AUDIO]